من جانبه اتهم زعيم المعارضه في اسرائيل
يا اير لابيد رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو بعدم الاكتراث للاضرار التي سببها
المؤتمر الداعي لعوده الاستيطان الى غزه
ومشاركه وزراء واعضاء كنيست من حزب
الليكود الحاكم في المؤتمر وقال لابيد ان
كل ما يكترث له نتنياهو هو البقاء في سده
الحكم حتى لو احترقت اسرائيل حسب تعبيره
مضيفا ان نتنياهو ليس مؤهلا لقياده
وانه حان الوقت لاستبداله حسب
قوله التراجيديه الكبرى هي مشاركه واسعه
لمسؤولين من حزب الليكود في المؤتمر وزراء
واعضاء في الكنيست شاركوا في هذه الهلوسه
هذا ما يحدث عند انعدام اي استراتيجيه
للحكومه بشان اليوم التالي بعد الحرب
والاستراتيجيه الوحيده التي تبقت لهم هي
قدوم المسيح المخلص في اليوم التالي سكوت
رئيس الحكومه يعني ان انه قال شيئا واحدا
لتحترق الدوله برمتها المهم ان ابقى في
سده الحكم الحزب الحاكم ظل طريقه وليس كفا
ليبقى في الحكم ورئيس الحكومه الذي وافق
على مشاركه هؤلاء المسؤولين في المؤتمر
ليس كفئا لقياده
اسرائيل معنا من رام الله ساري عرابي
الكاتب والباحث السياسيه مرحبا بك سيد
ساري ماذا تتوقع من رد اسرائيلي اولا على
م يعني على هذا التقدم الذي وصف بالبناء
في اتفاق تبادل
الاسر يعني اولا ما يوصف بالتقدم في اتفاق
تبادل الاسر في المفاوضات او المباحثات
الجاريه بين اطراف متعدده في باريس الكيان
الاسرائيلي هو جزء من هذه المباحثات
والمفاوضات ومن ثم ان كان هناك تقدم فهذا
يعني ان المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه على
الاقل هي موافقه على هذا التقدم او موافقه
على الاطر والمبادئ التاسيسيه لانه
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك الكثير من النقاش
والكثير من الخلافات حول قضايا اساسيه
وقضايا تفصيليه ولكن اطر هذا التفاهم واضح
ان هناك تقدم ما بالنظر الى مجموعه من
الملاحظات والتسريبات والقراءات
والتحليلات هذا يعكس بشكل او باخر موقف
المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه التي تدفع
نحو صيغه ما من التفاهم مع حركه حماس من
اجل الافراج عن الاسرى الاسرائيليين لدى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وربما من اجل التاسيس
لتصور ما من اجل الخروج من هذه المعركه
بصوره ما من شان بنيامين نتنياهو ان يقبل
بها او من شان بنيامين نتنياهو ان يسوقها
لدى حلفائه المختلفين والمتعدد ولا سيما
في احزاب الصهيونيه الدينيه التي تبتز
بنيامين نتنياهو وتمسك بنيمين نتنياهو
مرته كما هو معروفه القط هذه هذه النقطه
بالتحديد كنت اود ان اسالك بشانها كيف
سيسوق اي اتفاق اطار الان لدى هذه الاحزاب
الاكثر تشددا
ويمنيه اعتقد ان هناك قضيتين اساسيتين
الحقيقه في هذه الحرب العدوانيه على الف
فلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه ان الخروج من هذه
الحرب الحقيقه في صوره وقف اطلاق نار معلن
ومتفق عليه بين جميع الاطراف وانكفاء
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لن يكون سهلا على اي
صانع قرار اسرائيلي ليس فقط من يمين
نتنياهو وليس فقط في ظل هذا السياق
السياسي الذي تمارس فيه احزاب الصهيونيه
الدينيه هذا القدر العالي من التاثير
والنفوذ والابتزاز والانتهازي بطبيعه
الحال اسرائيل اعتقد انها وجدت نفسها في
الزاويه وفي مازق كبير وشديد في الحقيقه
لا سيما حينما سوقت ان هذه الحرب حرب
مصريه وحاولت ان تحشد كل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي خلف هذه الحرب ومن ثم الاتفاق
على وقف اطلاق نار معلن قد يكون صعبا لاي
صاحب قرار في اسرائيل ولذلك سوف نلاحظ
الموقف من وقف اطلاق النار او طبيعه
الصفقات متفاوت بين الذين هم في دوائر
اتخاذ القرار داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي
وبينهم الذين خارج اتخاذ القرار الامر
بطبيعه الحال سيكون اصعب في هذا السياق
السياسي ولا سما مع بنيامين نتنياهو وفي
ظل هذه الاحزاب التي لا ترفض فقط وقف
اطلاق النار او التي لا تقدم فقط
الاستمرار في الحرب على حساب الاسرى
الاسرائيليين الموجودين لدى المقاومه داخل
قطاع غزه ولكنها تدعو ايضا الى اعاده
احتلال قطاع غزه بل واعاده الاستيطان الى
داخل قطاع غزه ولذلك اظن ان بنيامين
نتنياهو ان وافق على هذه المبادئ بطبيعه
الحال موافقه مبدئيه سوف يبحث بطبيعه
الحال عن صيغه ما يسوق فيها هذا القرار
يستن الى مجموعه من الاعتبارات الاعتبار
الاول قد يكون ان الجيش الاسرائيلي حقق
اهداف مهمه جدا كما سوف يقولون بطبيعه
الحال على فيما يتعلق بتدمير القدرات
العسكريه لحركه حماس ثم سوف يقول ان هذا
ليس وقفا لاطلاق النار هذه هدنه قد تكون
طويله ومن ثم قد يكون الشكل النهائي
للخروج من هذا المشهد هو الخروج من المشهد
ولكن بصوره متعثره بمعنى قد نتحدث عن وقف
لهذه الحرب ولكنه وقف متعثر واعرج دون
الاتفاق على وقف لاطلاق النار وقد يكون
هذا مقبول لمختلف الاوساط الاسرائيليه طيب
هنا اي بالحديث عن العلاقه بين بنيامين
نتنياهو وهذه الاحزاب الدينيه المتطرفه
والمعارضه من جانب اخر في اي سياق تضع
ايه هذا المؤتمر الذي انتقدته المعارضه
ولكن شارك فيه اعضاء من الليكود ووزراء في
الحكومه مؤتمر تحت عنوان اعاده الاستيطان
الى الضفه وقطاع
غزه يعني هذا المؤتمر في الحقيقه يعبر عن
حاله الجنوح والنزوع لدى اليمين
الاسرائيلي عموما سواء كنا نتحدث عن
الصهيونيه الدينيه او كنا نتحدث عن
الصهيونيه القوميه في هناك قدر ما من
التراق الايديولوجي بين الصهيونيه القوميه
والصهيونيه الدينيه برفض وجود ممثل سياسي
للفلسطينيين وعدم الاعتراف باي كينونه
سياسيه او اي هويه سياسيه للفلسطينيين
ولذلك بنيامين نتنياهو بوصفه ممثلا
للصهيونيه القوميه كان رافضا بطبيعه الحال
لخطه شارون للانسحاب من قطاع غزه وفك
الارتباط عن الفلسطينيين لكن ثمت ارضيات
طبعا مختلفه لان بنيامين نتنياهو
والصهيونيه القوميه كانوا يراعوا الحسابات
الاستراتيجيه كانوا يراعوا الحسابات
السياسيه بطبيعه الحال وهم بشكل او باخر
جزء من البنيه التاريخيه للكيان
الاسرائيلي والتصورات الاسرائيليه
التاريخيه للصراع مع الفلسطينيين ومع
العرب عموما لكن نحن نتحدث عن طارئ على
السياسه الاسرائيليه بصوره او باخرى ممثل
بالصهيونيه الدينيه الذي لا يراعي
الحسابات الاستراتيجيه لا يراعي الحسابات
السياسيه وهو بالفعل كما تحدث لبيد يعني
يتبنى تصورات مسيحيه
خلصاني تهتم او تدفع نحو المزيد من الصراع
والمزيد من الحروب من اجل نزول ما يسمى
بالمسيح المخلص له مراعاه
المصالح يعني هذه هذا
تعبير لديه العديد من الخلف
هل لابيد او حتى المعارضه بالنسبه لهذا
المشروع الاستيطاني هم يرفضونه بالمبدا ام
يرفضونه نظرا للظروف الحاليه ولكن لو كانت
الظروف مختلفه لكانوا جزءا من هذا المشروع
مثلهم
مثل الصهيونيه
الدينيه هو لا شك ان المشروع الاستيطاني
لم يكن مشروعا خاصا بالصهيونيه الدينيه
ولم يك يكن مشروعا خاصا باليمين
الاسرائيلي المشروع الاستيطاني دفعت نحوه
وعززتها ودعمته مختلف الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه بما في ذلك ما يمكن
ان يسمى في حينه الحكومات اليساريه
والعماليه في ذلك الوقت ولكن كانت الرؤى
الاسرائيليه في ذلك الحين ايضا هي رؤى
استراتيجيه وسياسيه ولها اهداف استراتيجيه
وامنيه وسياسيه من الوجود الاستيطاني ولا
سيما داخل الضفه الغربيه تاريخيا كان في
هناك نوع من الافتراق بين مختلف الاوساط
السياسيه الاسرائيليه في كيفيات التعاطي
والتعامل مع الفلسطينيين ما بين الحديث عن
ضروره الاستمرار بالاحتلال الاسرائيلي او
ضم الضفه الغربيه كما يتحدث بمين نتنياهو
او استعاده حتى قطاع غزه كما تتحدث
الصهيونيه الدينيه او عن نوع من فك
الارتباط بطبيعه الحال واعطاء الفلسطينيين
مساحات للتحرك داخل الضفه الغربيه او
اقامه كيان سياسي فلسطيني من الممكن ان
يسمى دوله ولكن ضمن شروط معينه تبقي
للاسرائيليين وجودا استيطانيا وعسكريا
وامنيا داخل الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي من
الممكن ان نتحدث فيما يتعلق بالمعسكر
الاخر ليس بالضروره ان يكون لبيد ولكن
المعسكر الاخر الذي من الممكن ان يمثله
اليوم الجنرالات مثل جانتس وغيره الذين
لهم حضور سياسي في الساحه الاسرائيليه
ومصالح سياسيه بالتاكيد هؤلاء قد يتحدثوا
عن حل ما مع الفلسطينيين ولكن مع ضمانات
امنيه اسرائيليه هائله تبقي وجودا
اسرائيليا نافذا في ساحه الضفه الغربيه
على وجه الخصوص طيب سيد ساري لطالما قيل
بانه بعد انتهاء الحرب نتنياهو ذاهب الى
القضاء ستفتح ملفات المحاسبه ضده ولذلك هو
يطيل امد الحرب ما ماذا لو
بالفعل كان هناك اتفاق وجرى الاتفاق على
تبادل للرهائن والاسرى
وبالتالي يعني سيكون نتنياهو هنا في موضع
معين داخل القوى اليمينيه
وايضا المعارضه في اسرائيل كيف يمكن ان
يتصرف نتنياهو في تلك المرحله
الانتقاليه يعني بقدر ما بنيامين نتنياهو
يشعر بق قدرته على اللعب بجميع الحبال
واستثمار جميع الاطراف في المشهد السياسي
الاسرائيلي الداخلي وتوظيف الجميع بما في
ذلك التناقضات اذا كنا نتحدث عن اركان
مجلس الحرب ولاسم جانتس او كنا نتحدث عن
حلفائه التقليديين في الصهيونيه الدينيه
وران بنيمين نتنياهو التاريخي بانه الشخص
القادر ان يظهر للمجتمع الاسرائيلي بانه
الشخص القوي الحريص على مصلحه اسرائيل
والمناوئين للضغوط الامريكيه مع الاحتفاظ
بالدعم الامريكي للكيان الاسرائيلي وانه
قادر حتى على التاثير على القرار الامريكي
الداخلي رغم رهان بن نتنياهو على كل هذه
الاعتبارات والقضايا والتي نجح فيها طويلا
في الحقيقه في تجربته التاريخيه الا انه
يعلم تماما انه ايضا مازوم وان ازمته هي
ازمه صعبه ومستحق ومتعدده الاوجه ومتداخله
ولذلك انا اعتقد ان بنيمين نتنياهو ربما
يحاول يعني خلال المرحله القادمه ان يتخلص
يعني بمعنى ان يطالب بثمن ما اذا اراد ان
يذهب اكثر نحو حل ما تجاه الحرب العدوانيه
على الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه والخروج من
هذه الحرب ان يطالب بثمن ما من خلال
المعارضه الاسرائيليه ومن خلال الولايات
المتحده
الامريكيه ولك حاول بنيامين نتنياهو ان
يتقدم بنوع من الاستطلاع السياسي على هذا
الصعيد بمعنى اذا كنتم تريدون ان نذهب نحو
تسويات معينه وتفاهمات معينه على المستوى
السياسي الداخلي او على مستوى هذه الحرب
فاعطي بديلا يضمن لي ذلك الامان الذي
اطالب به غير ونفير ولذلك ربما سع بنيامين
نتنياهو لطرح تحالف جديد مع اوساط سياسيه
اخرى داخل الكيان الاسرائيلي ساري عرادي
الكاتب والبحث السياسي من رام الله شكرا
جزيلا لك